all we need is a spoonful of sugar and a
brand new Mary Poppins to bring us back
to our childhood everything is possible
even the impossible even the brand-new
Mary Poppins gave a nod to its iconic
original with Easter eggs which included
a very familiar-looking kite shoutouts
to the original the new movie has
several shout outs to the original but
if you weren't paying attention they can
be easily missed but if start with the
carpetbag and the iconic umbrella both
are back in the sequel they're a bit
more advanced for the stage since the
first movie however Mary still has a
very strange relationship with the
parrot in the movie we also see the
grown-up Jane and Michael searching
through the Attic they find a snow globe
which is not only a shout-out to the
first movie but also a reminder of the
popular toy you can get in real life of
course the snow globe features st.
Paul's Cathedral which is very prominent
in the first movie and the opening scene
of the second movie land flyer Jack
appears to be cycling past st. Paul's
unfortunately the place doesn't appear
in the rest of the movie however this
was a perfect Easter egg another nod to
the classic version is Mary saying to
the banks children that they should
close their mouths because they are
still not a codfish getting with the
times the old school mary poppins movie
is pretty old
it was made way back in 1964 and times
have definitely changed since then you
can kind of see that from some of the
really well hidden Easter eggs for
example Mary strange parrot umbrella is
no longer talking on its own it's now
remote-controlled because you know
technology has taken over in the modern
times even though the second movie is
still meant to be set sometime in 1935
although to be fair a non automated
talking parrot umbrella is still much
cooler and it's not the only example of
getting with the times we all remember
miss tanks and her adorable songs about
suffragettes back in the old days this
was the women's social and political
union which made sure women have the
right to vote it definitely played an
important part in the movie and of
course in real life in the sequel it
looks like Jane Banks followed her
mother's footsteps
she's a union organizer which is just a
perfect way of showing how inspiring
your family can be
let me look at you well you're not as
well turned out as I'd like the Robin
now let's check out some of the
individual Easter eggs because Mary
Poppins Returns has big shoes to fill it
made sure it's aware of just how much
influence the original movie actually
had it starts with Mary Poppins outfit
in case you haven't noticed
Mary's original hat features cherries
and daisies well flower power has been
replaced by a bird but it isn't just any
bird it's the same Robin that's shared a
duet with Mary Poppins in a spoonful of
sugar
seriously that animatronic bird really
knew how to sing so we're totally on
board with this homage Emily Blunt said
that she truly felt like Mary Poppins
when she tilted the hat with the bird
for the first time to be honest the bird
did have a lot of confidence and no
issues singing with the original Mary
Poppins
maybe his confident spirit now lies in
the Hat Ceylon tea now this one really
feels like a miserable Easter egg
honestly it's totally expected when you
have an attic full of items from your
childhood memories especially when the
childhood memories relate to Mary
Poppins we like the whole attic is just
actual props from the first movie or at
least we hope it is because this Easter
Egg pretty much indicates that this is
true pay attention to the part when
Michael carries the box with a kite
downstairs if you look at the box you'll
notice the words Ceylon tea written on
there this is actually a wooden tea
crate which appeared in the first movie
well sort of let's be honest the part
that no one paid attention to in the
first movie was the bank part but if you
do you know that mr. dolls jr. said that
a bank official once unwisely loaned a
large sum of money to finance a shipment
of tea to the American colonies mr.
banks said that the tea was thrown
overboard by a party of colonists looks
like mr. banks saved at least one of
those tea crates for himself
the entire moment is also a nod at the
fact that Michael is now a part-time
teller at the same Bank where his dad
used to work Karen dotrice say who the
name might not be familiar unless you're
a hardcore Mary Poppins fan but if we
say the og Jane Banks you know who we
are talking about you'll have to watch
the movie to actually catch this moment
it's been reported that it happens when
a woman gets asked for directions to
another house on Cherry Tree Lane the
woman is actually Karen dotrice who's
over 60 now it's been a long time since
she was a little girl known as Jane
Banks but it's really her her character
in the second movie doesn't have a name
she's only called an elegant woman but
it's safe to say that these words
definitely apply to Karen dotrice
seriously her red carpet appearances are
always marvelous and we bet this movie
was a special moments for her this also
pretty much means that the second Mary
Poppins film had two versions of Jane
Banks in the same movie the house maid
unless you actually search for the
answers there's a chance you won't even
recognize some of the old faces in the
new movie but when you do it'll make you
feel all warm and tingly inside because
some of the young or semi young folk
from the old movie are actually the old
people in the new movie take Ellen the
housekeeper for example although she
isn't played by the same actress she's
still the same old Ellen character he
might recognize the actress before you
even recognize the character it's Julie
Walters who also plays Molly Weasley in
the Harry Potter series
unlike Molly Weasley Ellen the
housekeeper doesn't really like to be
watching the children can't blame her
Michael and Jane banks are menaces
before Mary Poppins comes along but it
looks like it was Mary Poppins that made
Allan stay with the banks family after
everyone pretty much had a change of
heart things got better and she's not
even arguing with the cook anymore
although to be fair that's something we
actually miss the kites if you're a fan
of the original movie you've probably
had the kite song stuck inside your head
on more than one occasion and we
apologize if that's what you're singing
right now but unfortunately according to
the old Michael Banks that kite doesn't
fly anymore this of course is a part of
a symbolism that highlights the fact
that the kids have grown up the kite is
tucked away similar to how it was before
Mary Poppins came along the first time
the kite was also a symbol for fun and
childlike imagination so seeing it
abandoned is quite sad we all know miss
banks attached the votes for women tale
to the original kite which can still be
seen although not for Michael's box but
if we tell you where we'll spoil
everything so you'll just have to keep
your eyes glued to the screen if you
really want to catch this Easter egg pay
attention to the scenes towards the end
of the
don't worry you'll find out mr. dolls
jr. the name might not really ring a
bell
because again who really paid attention
to the scary bank scene back in the day
but that makes this easter egg even that
much sweeter so it was a huge steal that
lin-manuel miranda basically took over
dick Van Dyke's role the second movie
doesn't have Burt but the real-life Burt
did appear in the second movie in case
you didn't know Dick Van Dyke actually
played mr. DAWs senior in the first
movie it was a small role and he was
almost unrecognizable and he's back for
the second movie but he doesn't play mr.
dolls senior he plays mr. dolls junior
how crazy is that what's even funnier is
that dick Van Dyke's now aged to the
point where he looks kind of similar to
his original dolls character
can you imagine playing three characters
in the same themed movies we bet that
was a pretty special moment for this
iconic actor very well deserved the
Penguins are back one of the best things
about the very first Mary Poppins movie
were definitely the Penguins watching
that scene as a kid was so surreal come
on
real-life people entered a cartoon and
they pretty much got to hang out with
hilarious penguins the second movie kind
of recreates the magic joy once again
putting the real-life people in a
cartoon world but what's even better is
the fact that they brought back the
Penguins they must know just how popular
those penguins were back in the day and
just like their original this sequel
will also have four of these little
characters they're actually the ones
that asked Mary Poppins if she could
sing for them they also hide backstage
as if they know she was seeing anyways
of course nothing will ever replace the
adorable dorky penguins from the
original but hey we'll take what we can
get if you haven't seen the original or
totally forgot about the funny penguins
it's time to rewatch the iconic scene
Richard Sherman if you pay attention to
the opening titles
Richard M Sherman's name will pop up
Richard Sherman was a musical consultant
for the second movie but only og fans
will know that Richard and his late
brother Robert did the same in the first
movie the director of Mary Poppins
Returns joked that Richards billing
should say cheerleader because he
cheered them on every time they'd play
the new Mary Poppins music to him
according to Lin Manuel
and there are several easter eggs in the
music that are actually a nod to the
Sherman Brothers
he said the line that says Mary Poppins
it is so wonderful to see you again
features three notes of the song from
the first movie when said he had no idea
about some of these musical easter eggs
until he caught some during a radio
thing Angela Lansbury we might not get
the iconic Julie Andrews in the second
movie but we do get another icon most
Disney fans have probably heard of
people most likely no Angela Lansbury
from Bedknobs and Broomsticks and Beauty
and the Beast she didn't appear in the
first Mary Poppins but she did get a
role most people know from the original
books in the second movie she plays the
balloon lady it might not seem like an
important role especially since she only
appears towards the end for a few
seconds but she has a small dialogue
with Mary Poppins and what she says will
definitely make you cry we won't spoil
it for you but it will kind of make you
rethink your childhood and how you see
the world oh and in case you're
wondering Julie Andrews was of course
offered a role to appear in the movie
but she declined it in order to not
steal emily Blunt's thunder hamilton and
last but not least fans have discovered
a strange connection to Hamilton the
musical of course with lin-manuel
Miranda in this movie it would be weird
if there wasn't a Hamilton reference
this is an unconfirmed Easter egg and we
might be reaching but did you notice
that one of the lawyers working for mr.
banks Bank is called Hamilton Gooding in
our eyes it's a reference to Hamilton
and another Hollywood Broadway star Cuba
Gooding jr. the name Hamilton Gooding
does not appear in any other Mary
Poppins versions or books so it's safe
to say it would be strange if this is
just a coincidence
do you think this is a reference to
Hamilton or is the character completely
unrelated and that's it for our video
don't forget to subscribe to the things
for more feel-good content thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]